[Music]
are you real Stevenson the CEO of a tea
yes I am is that a 5g phone no we don't
have 5g out yet what's 5g anyway is it
gonna make my phone work better in this
elevator five years fifth generation
that works it's wireless technology yeah
actually think of it like a fiber optic
cable connected to your phone that's
what it'll be like so way faster way
faster it'll just be totally
instantaneous you make a command and
boom it will happen do you saw the
landline yeah I do my mom still has one
to Ma Bell cannot go without a landline
telephone what do you think will be the
greatest benefit of 5g well when it's
instantaneous now you can start to think
about driverless cars the fact I would
say you don't want to think about a
driverless car with a network that has
delay right 18 t now owns Warner Media
which on CNN what are your thoughts on
the White House banning CNN reporter Jim
Acosta well I think it's a concern you
think about free speech and have a White
House take away the White House
credentials without really any kind of
due process is a a concern when you
think about the importance of Free Press
in this country president Trump has also
been really critical of CNN what do you
think of his criticism well I think
CNN's job is not to be popular with the
president CNN's job is really simple
it's the job of all the media to hold
people in power accountable why do I
keep getting these robo calls are you
being chased by the IRS - yes they're
frustrating aren't they are you sure
you're not the fake IRS I'm quite
confident I'm not because that fake IRS
is calling me as well calling my mother
it scares her to death
we're working on this the technology
exists fixes we need rules from the
to address it what would you like to see
happen next to the net neutrality debate
I'd like to see something novel happen
on the net neutrality debate and that is
Congress passed laws about what the
rules should be as opposed to letting
our regulators have to play legislature
all the time you were president of the
Boy Scouts of America square knot or
bowline knot oh I'm a Davey guy
fly-fishing it's the best not for
fly-fishing
the Boy Scouts are changing their name
to Scouts BSA and allowing girls in
what's your take on the change so I
think the change has been long overdue
are you worried about Girl Scout cookies
must I hope not i buy them every year I
tend to keep buying Girl Scout cookies
okay favorite Girl Scout cookie oh it's
definitely similar what technology not
from your company are you most excited
about hitting in the next couple of
years
oh I think definitely blockchain
technology I mean the the idea that we
could have really really great security
and everything that we're doing online
it's a it's a game changer
Samoas
no service gotta go text and make some
class good luck with that I'm gonna make
mine here